What you've been writing and thinking about and people's reaction to it
intersects with tonight's debate.
Uh,
because you've been quite vocal on the topic of political correctness.
No fan of the radical left and it,
you know,
and people might say,
well,
does that mean you support the radical,
right?
It's like,
just because you're no fan of the radical left doesn't mean you support the
radical,
right?
That's an absolutely a preposterous proposition.
But the universities,
especially the humanities and social sciences,
are absolutely dominated by left wing thinking.
That's well documented by people like Jonathan Heit.
It's not my imagination.
And I find the doctrine that unites them to be unconscionably pernicious.
It's basically a collectivist doctrine.
And the thing that disturbs me about it,
but there's every reason to have a left wing.
The reason you need a left wing is partly because being left wing is in part
temperamental.
It's not going away.
And also because when our society produces hierarchies,
which will inevitably do,
people tend to stack up at the bottom of hierarchies.
It's in the nature of hierarchies to produce that as an outcome.
And what that means is that the people who are dispossessed in the hierarchical
arrangements need a voice and that's the left obviously,
and and fair enough.
But it's also obvious that just as the right can go too far,
the left can go too far,
but when the left goes too far is something that's very ill defined.
And to me that's,
that's not acceptable given that we know that the left can go too far and I
think they've certainly gone too far in the universities and the postmodern neo
Marxists pastiche that makes up the radical left philosophy that's at the bottom
of the social sciences and humanities now is there's nothing about it that's
useful as far as I'm concerned,
that has nothing to do with compassion,
has nothing to do with lack of my lack of,
what would you say?
Empathy.
Yeah,
precisely.
They're completely separate issues.
And that's another thing that really bothers me about political correctness.
It's like,
well,
we have a hammer lock on empathy.
It's like a empathy is not enough.
It's not even close to enough.
And an excess of empathy can do terrible things.
And B,
no,
you don't have a hammerlock on empathy.
And to ally that with a philosophy that essentially assigns people to their
identity via their group membership.
And then to read not only the current state of affairs,
but history itself as a battleground between competing groups is,
I think it's dangerous.
I think it's obvious that it's dangerous if you know anything about history,
but one you're sure to hear tonight
is this idea of privilege that certain people by virtue,
uh,
Uni,
by virtue of our,
our race,
our class,
our gender,
have enjoyed historically privilege in society and it's time that that privilege
be shared more equitably across groups who've been historically disadvantaged.
Well,
that's a good example of the conflation of empathy with ideology.
It's like first of all,
the majority in any society has privilege.
That's the whole point of the society is to set up a system so that the bulk of
the people in the system can do well while,
and then you have you built in protection for minorities.
So to conflate that with race is not acceptable.
It's a kind of,
it's a toxic sleight of hand and it's extraordinarily dangerous.
So apart from that,
it's an empty claim.
Some people have advantages that other people don't.
Well obviously,
and if you take apart anyone into the multitude of categories that they can be
taken apart into,
what you'll find is that on some of those dimensions,
they're doing better than other people for rather arbitrary reasons sometimes.
And on other dimensions they're doing worse.
So it purple.
And then the next part of that is while historically speaking,
it's like,
okay,
over what span of time do you mean?
Precisely so you mean because my ancestors 150 years ago were privileged
comparatively speaking,
that I should somehow pay for that now.
And Are you so sure.
My ancestors were so privileged as far as I can tell.
My grandparents on my father's side,
my father grew up in a log cabin until he was five.
He had like three rooms.
My grandmother was a cleaning woman,
fur fur farms in the,
in this,
in central Saskatchewan in the 1930s she cooked for threshing cruise.
You know,
she chopped wood piles that were as big as the damn cabin to get through the
winter.
It's like where?
Where's the privilege?
I see it accrues to me as a consequence of my race.
Oh,
I see.
So we're now we're going to have a discussion about race are Wayne.
That's,
and that's the thing about the toxic left is that everything is about group
identity.
And so let's say,
let's even take the argument further though and say,
okay,
well because of my skin color,
I'm differentially privileged.
Okay.
So from,
from a historical perspective,
so,
so what you're going to make everybody be on the basis of their race now pay for
some historical inequity and you're going to view the,
the history of the relationships between men and women as one fundamentally of
oppression.
That's the way we're going to play this is that it wasn't that men and women see
fundamentally cooperated throughout history to bring themselves out of the
fundamental catastrophe that history has always been.
That isn't what it was.
Despite the fact that in 1895 the typical person in the western world lived on
less than a dollar a day.
By today's standards,
which is far below the UN's current guidelines for abject poverty.
We're going to revisit that.
We're going to say no.
Really,
the fundamental reality of the world was that men are oppressed women.
It's like,
yeah.
So that brings me to a second argument that you are no doubt going to hear
tonight,
which is that,
you know,
men need to check their privilege.
That there's an idea here that,
uh,
you know,
women in particular the me too movement.
There's been a,
an awareness and awakening the part of the power of women in society and it's
time that,
that be acknowledged.
What will be your response to that?
Well,
first of all,
when the discussion is about power,
you know,
that sends a shutter up my spine immediately,
partly because part of the postmodern doctrine,
especially in its alliance with neo Marxism,
which is squirrel,
strangest alliance by,
by my estimates,
everything's about power.
And I don't believe that.
I think that hierarchies are only about power when they've already transformed
themselves into tyrannies.
And I don't think that the fundamental hierarchies that characterize the west
art t radical comparatively speaking,
like compared to the heavenly hierarchy in your utopian imagination,
no doubt there exemplars of pure hell,
but compared to everywhere else in the world right now and every other hierarchy
throughout history,
we're doing pretty damn well.
And the fact is is that once we had reliable birth control,
which really only happened in the 1960s,
women were welcomed most fundamentally,
although also opposed,
but most fundamentally welcomed into every position of authority and competence
that could possibly be laid open to them,
to the point where now they make up something like it's damn near three quarters
of humanities and social sciences students,
they dominate the healthcare fields.
So how fast do you expect the transformation to take place?
While the argument is,
well,
it would've never happened without political pressure.
It's like,
yeah,
no,
sorry.
What triggered it was reliable birth control and that made it possible.
It was reliable,
birth control and reliable,
um,
menstrual sanitation and all of those things that no one ever takes into account
that made the playing field open and it's transformed utterly.
And in what,
50 years,
how fast do you think these things can happen?
Good point.
So,
and I'm certainly not against equality of opportunity.
You have to be here.
You have,
I dunno what has to be wrong with you to be against equality of opportunity.
You know,
even if you're selfish,
if you're not absolutely out for destruction and you're only selfish,
let's say anybody with any sense would go for equality of opportunity at least
because it gives you the possibility of exploiting the maximum number of
qualified and talented people.
So,
and equality of outcome.
Well,
we'll save that for the debate tonight.
I'm sure it'll come up.
Final question.
I'm asking all of you pre debate.
Where do you think this debate is going to go from here?
Do you think we're,
we're in a kind of cultural spasm or do you think there's something more
fundamental happening in our culture,
a new tribalism,
a new set of antagonisms they're going to take much longer to work at?
I think it'll depend on how well we each behave in the next 10 years because I
think things could get way better everywhere really fast,
or we could degenerate back into our idiot 20th century.
Tribalisms and I would say,
if I had to bet,
well,
you know,
it's,
what are you seeing?
You're out there,
you're in the public's.
Uh,
I,
I really,
I would say that
there's plenty of pressure in both directions.
You know,
I'm heartened by the fact that so many people
have been taking the psychological material that I've been providing online to
heart and doing what they can to put themselves together.
I'm disheartened by the fact that
everything now is transformed into,
well,
virtually everything is transformed into a polarized political argument.
And there seems to be no understanding of the fact that not everything is
actually political.
I actually don't think that,
I don't think the discussion about political correctness,
political,
I think it's,
I think it's both theological and philosophical,
but it's,
it's always presented are often presented in politicize terms,
not least because if you're influenced by the radical leftist collective
collectivist ideology,
that is the only playing field.
It's all hierarchies at each other's throats playing power games.
It's it.
The free speech thing is really interesting because on the radical left end of
things,
this,
there is no debate about free speech.
You can't have a debate about free speech from that ideological position because
there isn't any such thing.
All there is is those who are maneuvering for power within their respective
groups making claims that benefit from,
yeah.
That's the basic axiom of the interpretive system,
so free speech.
It isn't that it isn't.
The reason that free speech has become politicized is because
if you adopt the collectivist viewpoint,
it's a shibboleth.
It's a fantasy.
You might think you're speaking freely,
but you're not.
You're just expanding on that.
How prevalent gender absolutely.
Smile.
My Rez.
Anyway,
part,
one of the things that's funny about the postmodern insistence on identity,
I think it's absolutely comical in a very,
very dark,
is the emergence of intersectionality because the intersectional theorists
actually identified the Achilles heel of the collectivist perspective.
You know,
because what they pointed out was,
well,
let's say we cover the standard groups.
I don't know why these are the standard groups,
but let's say sex,
ethnicity and race for the sake of argument.
Well,
what about how they interact?
It's like,
yeah,
what about that?
What about the fact that gender is infinitely differentiable,
not least from the left wing perspective.
And what about the fact that there's endless numbers of ethnic variance and what
are you going to do?
You're going to control for the interaction between all of those.
And the answer is yes.
That's what we'll try to do before we give up our radiology.
But the fact of the matter is,
is that the reason the west decided on a radical,
individualistic perspective to begin with is because we figured out 2000 years
ago,
at least at the origins of this type of thinking that,
okay,
everyone is so unique that you can frack,
you can fraction hate their group identity right down to the level of the
individual.
[inaudible] well,
so,
yeah.
Yeah.
I don't know what's going to happen.
I think the universities for example,
I think they've done themselves yet.
I don't think they can escape from,
cause I,
I,
I've watched large organizations crumble and that can happen very often and
okay.
One serious error.
We'll do it.
And I think I've tried to lay it out.
I think the universities have made seven serious errors.
You don't want,
we're gonna have to say those for the stage tonight and then universities will
absolutely be a topic of our discussion.
Okay.
But a real pleasure to get a taste for your remarks and appreciate your passion
and your,
uh,
a willingness to,
to step onto the stage and engage with other people's ideas in a spirit of free
and open exchange.
Yeah.
Hopefully it will go well and it'll be an intelligent discussion and we'll get
somewhere.